oh yeah I've watched the video again and
I didn't make the point well but I but I
was leading you toward it and you got
there so good but this is my point that
like it's with with like an ecological
metaphor you can look a couple of steps
down the road and you can say okay well
right now uh like I can see that they're
gonna be things traveling around in our
society that are going to be unlike
things that have existed before they
they may feel like humans to us but they
won't be humans they won't be able to do
everything that humans can do but
everything that they do will look human
to us that's like an invasive species
that's like a rat in Hawaii a mammal in
a place where there's never been mammals
before
but then also we can continue down that
metaphor and say what are we going to
release to control them and is that also
going to be a problem because they're
also going to be a new thing we're going
to be totally ignorant of how that's
actually going to work so there's
another level there's our reaction to it
which oftentimes is just as bad as the
introduction of the thing itself